en
ym
depuis dix ans m pour montréal certes
d'entremetteur entre les artistes d'ici
et les diffuseurs internationaux
c'est en 2006 en plein triomphe d'arcade
fire
kenny cet événement qui fait rayonner
les artistes de la métropole un accident
parcours institut voir le en 2006 ça a
été un appel de monsieur martin en
bouche programme d'ailleurs la scène
principale du festival glastonbury india
écoute on aimerait se moins quelques
amis passer par montréal une petite
soirée on s'en va tout à new york pour
un autre congrès est comme ça que la
première année une incroyable
patrick watson l'ex dj champion galaxy
depuis une décennie m pour montréal est
des groupes comme matt moulson a percé à
l'international c'est certain qu'en 2006
j'étais l'on imaginé que m devient driss
cet accélérateur de carrière cet outil
de développement carrière
parmi les faits saillants des dix
dernières années il y a eu le spectacle
2 monsters in men d' adam cohen et le
passage remarqué jean semaines venus
présenter des groupes émergence sa
personnalité un dialecte que fait
connaître localement et prom oriente les
artistes francophones occupent également
une place de choix dans la série franco
m qui met en vedette cette année pierre
quander safia nolin et fils et braque
c'est devenu juste un ventre avec le
temps plus un moment pour les
professionnels de nos pays de 10 alors
on va avoir un moment où ce qu on
vraiment découvrir un autre côté de
montréal du québec qu'on connaît moins
parce qu'il entende plus parler des
groupes anglophones
m pour montréal ne compte pas prendre
plus d'expansion on a décidé d'être
vraiment plus une boutique la petite
boutique ou aux objets précieux
finalement versé en espèces de
supermarché m pour montréal présente
cette année plus de 130 artistes dont
grinds qui affiche déjà complet au
métropolis ici tanya lapointe à
radio-canada m'ont rien